[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with political correspondent at the
financial times Jasmine Cameron gileshi
and economics editor of The Spectator
Kate Andrews so let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now on the
front of the eye striking nurses a
warning sunac to improve wage offer or
face more walkouts as the latest wave of
strikes hit any intensive care and
cancer awards for the first time
on the front of the telegraph cancer
nurses go on strike for the first time
with the head of the RCN Pat Cullen
warning industrial action could go on
for years
meanwhile the front of the Daily Mail
reports that the UK Hospitality sector
is set for a one billion pound boost
thanks to the coronation and also
Liverpool's hosting of the Eurovision
song contest
the build up to the coronation continues
on the front of the mirror which reports
that Prince William will pay tribute to
King Charles and Camilla in a heartfelt
speech after the coronation concert
The Daily Express reports that
pensioners were underpaid and
extraordinary 530 million pounds last
year due to Errors By officials the
paper says 1.3 million older people are
affected
on the front page of the financial times
a report on U.S Bank First Republic
nearing collapse with three large Banks
bidding for the troubled lender
meanwhile The Daily Star warned that
homes are under threat from a plague of
300 million obese rats
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
the political correspondent at the
financial times Jasmine Cameron chileshi
and economics editor of The Spectator
Kate Andrews welcome to you both let's
start first off with the Telegraph and
the nurses strike which commenced this
evening but the difference this time
cancer nurses are on strike also Jasmine
yeah so this latest action by the Royal
College of Nursing really represents an
escalation in this industrial dispute so
as the telegraph knows for the first
time nurses on cancer boards will be
striking we also know that nurses on
some emergency departments and intensive
care boards are also taking part in the
strike and this comes after The Royal
College of Nursing rejected the
government's pay offer um which I think
included a one-off payment and a five
percent pay hike for this financial year
and I think there's a real sense of
trepidation among NHS leaders who are
concerned that the longer term impact
that these strikes can have now as is
often the case with these strikes um the
NHS has said that um if they're if
you're in a life-threatening situation
you can still call the service and
you'll still be treated but some of the
bigger impacts will be felt on some of
the appointments and elect of operations
that will need to be postponed or
rescheduled as a result of these strikes
and so there is a lot of une ease among
NHS leaders at what impact this can have
and I think there is a real feeling of
of weariness at the moment I think of
where this um where the strike action
ends the our Sienna calling on the
government to put forward an improved
offer and we heard from
um transport secretary Mark Harper and
the health secretary today arguing that
the offer that they've put forward to
unions is actually a fair one and so we
seem to have hit a bit of a stalemate
and of course it will be
um you know patients that will be
feeling the brunt of this and all of
this puts a lot of pressure on the
government to really get back to the
negotiating table and find some sort of
resolution
yes I mean exemptions have been agreed
Kate but um what do you think the
repercussions will be in terms of public
support for the nurses striking
there is a lot of public support still
for the nurses in particular but as
these NHS Strokes continue to go on
already hundreds of thousands of
operations and appointments have been
canceled the more that happens the more
frustrated ill patients are going to
become indeed
this is a tricky territory for both the
RCN and the government because uh the
the pay deal was rejected not by a huge
margin was about 56 of the RCN members
who voted who decided to reject the deal
um and and so you know it was much
closer than a lot of people expected and
you do have other unions like Unison
which have accepted the pay deal so I
think the pressure is on there but of
course the concern for the government
and what the RCN leaders and other NHS
leaders are banking on is that if they
rebalot their members which they're
planning to do and strike for another
six months that takes them close to 2024
and that takes us probably into an
election year
um and so uh you know that's that's
tricky territory for the government as
well so no party's doing too well out of
these negotiations going on and on and
on and as you point out there Jillian
there have been exceptions that are
going to be made to make sure there's a
minimum standard of service in in the
emergency rooms but that is not applying
to cancer services and I think you know
we could certainly debate whether or not
cancer Services should be in the
emergency category I think they should
and and so they're going to be yet again
so many crucial appointments canceled
these are not necessarily just routine
appointments really important ones that
are being canceled and it you know as
Jasmine says it's really putting
pressure on everybody to come to the
table because increasingly nobody looks
as if they're going to win this very
horrible debate that's taking place in
such a public way and Jasmine removed to
the eye and they have the warning from
the nurses themselves to the Prime
Minister that the wage offer needs to be
improved or there will be more walkouts
and also I think one of the papers was
quoting Pat Cullen is saying that this
dispute could go on for years
potentially
um it was actually really interesting
listening to Pat Cullen who was on Sky
earlier this morning as she was laying
out the Union's case for continued
industrial action and essentially saying
yes she understood the concerns by NHS
leaders that you know the potential
risks but also her counter argument is
that actually some of the underlying
problems in the NHS that nurses are
striking against are also putting
patients at risk so so notably star
shortages and some of the working
conditions that
um nurses have to have to perform their
jobs under and I think it's you know
it's quite interesting to see where this
um debate where this issue will
eventually land because part of the um
you know one of the points that's being
put forward by some of the health unions
is that there's a lot of underlying
problems within the Health Service that
do need to be addressed and we know this
is not just about pay it's about working
conditions it's about the turnover of
Staff it's about hours there are all
these very existential questions that
are being asked of the NHS are being
asked of the government at the moment
and so you know I would be very
surprised if this is a master that can
be included in a matter of days I think
we are you know both sides are getting
ready for a very prolonged
um fight over this
guessing Kate as you were alluding to
earlier
um the RCN um Insider according to the
bi is suggesting that the extended
strikes will damage the prime minister
at the polls I mean it would be in his
interest going into a pre-election year
to get this this sorted but we just
don't seem to be any closer to that
well you can see that the labor party
had been trying to capitalize on these
traits when it comes to putting to the
government why aren't you able to settle
this why aren't you able to get doctors
and nurses back into hospital to see
their patients you know they're taking a
very political line on this and they're
hoping that will be to their advantage
because of course it does look bad to
have these strikes continuing for months
and months and months on end of course
the the other side of that equation
um is the fact that as I said you do
have some unions accepting the deal that
will encourage the government stands
which is that they are offering
something that should be seen as fair or
at least something that should settled
the issue for now and perhaps something
to return to later
um and as well there's a question of
where the money actually comes from of
course because we're talking across the
board of billions and billions of pounds
that are going to be pledged
indefinitely because these are salaries
you know for future years as well it's
not necessarily going to be a one-off
payment
um so you know really difficult
questions and and whilst the labor party
is trying to capitalize on this they
have also strongly hinted that they
probably wouldn't be able to deliver
some of the requests that we've seen
around say the junior doctor is asking
for more than a 30 pay raise
um you know some of the nurses starting
around 19 and you know these are really
Hefty pay raises that even the labor
party has started to concede they
probably could have fully deliver on
um but of course they're not in charge
the Tory party is and and this does
fundamentally remain a headache for
number 10. indeed Jasmine take us to the
ft and the fears of a U.S Bank collapse
uh First Republic we're talking about
yes so the papers reporting that
um around two banks have submitted
um bids to try to save this struggling
um bank and obviously it comes in the in
the midst of the collapse of the Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank and I
think at the moment there's just a lot
of uncertainty in the financial sector
certainly no one's suggesting that this
is a repeat of the 2008 financial crash
but there is a there is a feeling of
unease and actually I think there are a
lot of questions now being asked of some
of the um Regulators in in the US in
Europe and you know how closely were we
looking at some of these and financial
institutions there are questions for the
institutions themselves as to what
cultures they were working under whether
they had put in place sustainable
um means to kind of whether you know any
sort of changes in the global economy be
that the war or the hike in interest
rates so yeah it's a very um there's a
lot of unease at the moment in the in
the sector and obviously the US
regulators and these various banks that
are trying to put in bids that are
hoping that they're trying to secure
some sort of deal before the markets
open next week and Kate it does seem
quite an extreme situation with First
Republic shares um they've lost more
than 97 of their value this year that's
an incredibly high amount
yes for First Republic it seems a lot of
the assets that they were holding to
have lost significant value over this
year and this is now an extension of the
regional banking crisis that we have
seen in the United States of course with
Silicon Valley Bank we discovered that
um you know they had not properly hedged
interest rates and they had just assumed
that they would stay ultra low forever
and of course that turned out not to be
the case so in many of these instances
we're seeing the effects that Rising
rates can have and of course we're not
talking about huge escalations actually
historically interest rates are still
quite normal if not on the low side but
assumptions were made and even
Regulators as Jasmine says seem to go
seem to go along with these assumptions
and they were fundamentally wrong but
the real goal of government now is to
make sure that first Republic has a
buyer before markets open or almost as
soon as a very close to aftermarkets
open because the real concern at this
point is that you don't start getting
such levels of instability that it makes
investors even more nervous when it
comes to the Widing banking sector so if
you can show that there are people who
who are interested that there are buyers
and big banks that think can see this as
a potential investment for the future
that will hopefully offset any kind of
run that you might see on bigger Banks
uh so you know the goal right now is to
do this in a very short period of time